il explique bah qu'il se baladait ce
jour-là dans Perpignan c'est un soir le
temps est pas vraiment Clément il fait
quelques gouttes il rentre à son hôtel
monar shbelle rentre chez elle hein cité
universitaire
elle est sur l'autre trottoir il
traverse le trottoir et puis là les les
choses s'enchaînent il la menace il la
menace d'une arme d'un couteau en
l'occurrence il a contraint à à le
suivre dans un endroit un peu plus isolé
puisque sont dans la rue hein et puis et
puis voilà et puis l'oblige ensuite à
voir un certain nombre de gestes sur
lesquels je je m'étonnerai pas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
on voit que le meurtrier a pris soin qui
nait plus aucune trace qui permett de
l'identifier il y a la psychose qui se
crée il y avait des similitudes qui
permettaient de penser qu'il y avait un
criminel
unique je repense à ses corps et là je
me dis c'est Tatiana qui a subi le même
sort on touche en fin du doigt la la
solution tout le monde s'est posé la
question est-ce que nous avions arrêté
le tueur dans sis la garde de Perpignan
ce monsieur a énormément de chance je
dis ce monsieur je dis pas ce monstre
j'attends qu' crève quelle que soit la
vérité aussi difficile soit-elle je
préfère savoir la
[Musique]
vérité
tatianaia
et
Fatima quatre femmes brunes belles et
jeunes disparu l'une après l'autre dans
un même périmètre le quartier de la gare
de
perpignon une enquête tentaculaire un
casse-tête pour les policiers des
dizaines de suspects désespoir déçu et
un dénouement inespéré 20 ans plus tard
grâce à une trace ADN un dénouement
partiel car l'affaire des disparus de la
gare conserve aujourd'hui encore une
part de mystère
avec imali nous avons décidé de
retrouver ses protagonistes et
d'analyser avec eux les conséquences et
les répercussions de ce dossier hors
norme France Bleu Rousillon les infos
avec vous C man Jacques Ron avait déjà
avoué le meurtre de mariaib une
étudiante elle aussi mutilée en décembre
97 en garde à vue depuis hier à
Perpignan il a donc reconnu être
l'auteur de ce second meurtre celui de
marie-élène
Gonzalez
tout commence le dimanche 24 septembre
1995 Tatiana andujard 17 ans vient de
passer le weekend avec des amis à
Toulouse ses parents attendent son
retour le dimanche soir mais Tatiana ne
rentre pas le lundi matin il signale sa
disparition à la
gendarmerie les gendarmes retrouvent des
témoins qui l'ont aperçu dans le train
du retour Tatiana est donc rentrée à
Perpignan le dimanche soir à 19h30 puis
plus rien
elle a voyagé avec un jeune militaire
qui s'appelle David un caporal chef sont
même fait un petit bisou devant la gare
il y a des témoins qui les ont vu qui
les ont trouvé très mignons en train de
se dire au revoir de changer les les
coordonnés téléphoniques et de là plus
rien elle prend la rue Riber qui est
juste à 50 m de la gare pour aller vers
le café figire faire du stop où tous les
étudiants de Perpignan font du stop mais
au café figire personne ne se souvient
avoir vu Tatiana ce soir-là
l'adolescente s'est volatilisée en
sortant de la gare les semaines passent
et toujours aucun signe de
vie une information judiciaire est
ouverte pour enlèvement le juge reprend
les témoignages 1 à un en 20ain en mai
1997 1 an et demi après la disparition
de Tatiana un non lieu est prononcé les
recherches sont abandonnées
Marie José Garcia qui était Tatiana
Tatiana était une jeune très jolie fille
très souriante très
sociable très rieuse pleine de vie elle
aimait danser elle aimait chanter
elle aimait
vivre lorsqu'elle disparaît quelles
hypothèses vous
envisagez dans dans un premier temps moi
je sais que c'est grave je sais que
c'est grave parce que je connais ma
fille je sais que c'est grave parce que
Tatiana nous appeler pour nous dire je
rentre je ne rentre pas tout va bien ou
donc je comprends je comprends dès lundi
midi que c'est grave quelle est votre
réaction quand ce non lieu est prononcé
je rentre dans une colère terrible parce
que pour moi un sentiment de
d'abandon d'abandon de la part de la
justice qui nous abandonne mais qui
surtout abandonner ma
fille l'enquête sur la disparition de
Tatiana Andujar est donc
classée 6 mois plus tard le 21 décembre
1997 on retrouve le corps d'une autre
jeune fille sur un terrain vague de
Perpignan très vite elle est identifiée
elle s'appelle Moktaria shahib elle a 19
ans on retrouve ce corps je vous dis
exposé alors avec des
coupures des ablations complètement
dénudé
exang une trace de sang plusieurs coups
de couteau dans le cœur une lame fine
les découpes corporelles sont
précises dira
chirurgical l'autopsie révèle que la
jeune fille a été vidée de son sang et
de ses entrailles ses seins et ses
organes sexuels ont été amputés après sa
[Musique]
mort
un meurtre sauvage barbare insoutenable
pour la famille de
moctaria Mohamed vous avez une idée de
qui a pu lui faire ça non jamais dans la
vie
non un inhumain un monstre
votre famille vous comment vous vous
réagissez vous
comprenezétais jeune à l'époque j'avais
12 ans
euh vu si je vous dis à l'âge de 12 ans
comment réagit à
ça on a pas les mots on n pas les mots
on sait que c'est
grave on sait que ça ça boulevere une
famille on sait que ça va changer la vie
d'une
famille et votre sœur Mar qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire d'elle Mo cétait
une très belle femme très belle femme
très
gentille et voilà elle avait la vie
devant
[Musique]
elle les policiers ratissent le quartier
il retracent l'emploi du temps de
mocttaria le soir de sa disparition elle
était chez un ami elle l'a quitté vers
22h30 pour rentrer chez elle dans sa
nouvelle chambre
universitaire mcttaria est parti à pied
et fatalement en partant du domicile de
son copain qui était près de la venue de
la gare logiquement il fallait qu'elle
passe comme Tatiana rue Courteline donc
c'est sur ce trajet qu'elle a été
enlevée ou qu'elle est monté en stop
avec un un
automobiliste qui l'a donc
tué
tpessé et ensuite l'a ramené sur le
trajet sur son propre
trajet les policiers sont persuadés que
pour avoir découpé le corps avec une
telle précision l'auteur pourrait être
un chirurgien un vétérinaire ou un
boucher très vite un homme attire leur
attention il habite à 200 m du terrain
vague c'est un médecin péruvien il
s'appelle Andr palomino barios l'homme
de 49 ans est interne à l'hôpital de
Perpignan il a écumé tous les centres
hospitaliers de heagone à chaque fois il
a été mis à la porte pour incompétence
palomino barios a déjà eu affaire à la
justice il est connu pour des des vols
et des escroqueries c'est un beau
suspect après 15 jours de surveillance
le 22 janvier
1998 la police l'interpelle fouille son
studio et découvre des traces de
sang bingo dès le départ parce que les
traces de sang elles sont elles sont
visibles elles sont on dirait même elles
sont parlantes il y en a sur les murs il
y en a sur des vêtements il y en a dans
l'viier il y en a
partout du sang partout mais aussi des
scalpelles et du matériel chirurgical
palomino Bario s'est aussitôt placé en
garde à vue il ni toute implication et
explique qu'il était en Espagne au
moment des fait un alibi qui ne convint
pas les policiers ils ont beau chercher
des preuves pour confondre le Péruvien
il ne trouvent rien les premierers
prélèvement qui reviennent le sang ah
oui effectivement du sang mais c'est du
sang de
poulet sur ses pulls sur des vêements à
lui son propre sang parce qu'il
s'essuyait quand il se rasait qu' se
coupait avec ses affaires et sans les
laver ses affaires derrière donc
forcément il y avait toutes ces tâches
toutes ces traces et il y en avait
partout un revers pour les enquêteurs
qui restent pourtant persuadé de tenir
leur coupable palomino Bario s donc
maintenu en détention provisoire et
attend d'être fixé sur son sort 2 ans et
demi après Tatiana andujard et 6 mois
après la découverte du corps de mtaria
shahib une trème jeune fille disparaît
elle s'appelle Marie-Hélène gonzalz elle
a 22
[Musique]
ans conception
gonzalz votre fille dis pararu le 16
juin 1998
oui elle m'a téléphoné comme quoi elle
arrivait avec les tring de 9h et
justement moi je travaillais j'ai pas pu
aller la chercher elle m'a dit ne
t'inquiète pas maman je me débrouillerai
comme je sais qu'elle était elle s'est
brouillé par elle-même et j'avais
toujours confiance donc je me suis pas
inquiétée à 10h je suis arrivée et j'ai
demandé à mon mari si Marie-Hélène était
rentrée il m'a dit non j'ai pris ma
voiture je suis partie à Perpignan et
j'ai ris tout Perpignan ça voir si je la
trouvé ou à quelque part dev un café ou
j'ai j'ai rudé tout toutes les avenues
et j'ai pas
trouvé les policiers retracent
l'itinéraire de Marie-Hélène elle serait
arrivée en gare de Perpignan à 21h
ensuite elle a probablement fait du stop
comme à son habitude c'est-à-dire
exactement ce que devait faire Tatiana
le même trajet au même moment et avec la
même
intention les enquêteurs reprennent
immédiatement le dossier de Tatiana
andujard disparu presque 3 ans plus
tôt c'est alors qu'un chiffonniier fait
une découverte macabre près de la sortie
du péage de pè pignon il découvre une
partie du corps j'ai une partie du corps
parce que le cadavre il manque la tête
les poigné elle a été
vicérée ce cadavre c'est celui de
Marie-Hélène gonzalz retrouvé 10 jours
après sa
disparition au début je revenais pas
j'ai c'est pas possible je d c'est pas
possible que soit
elle il y avais la colère et tout qui
montait je croyais pas je croyais pas
mes yeux
vous avez pu la voir non on m'a dit
qu'il fallait pas que je la vois parce
qu'elle
était était décapité et de main trancher
il était toute je pouvais pas
laavir vous avez pas pu lui dire au
revoir
[Musique]
non les enquêteurs en sont persuadés
c'est le même homme qui a tué mcttaria
et
Marie-Hélène le corps n'a pas de tâche
de sang donc apparemment
exand et n'est dénudé complètement
dénudé comme
moctaria et alors la constante aussi
entre l'affaire moctaria et l'affaire de
marilè on voit que le meurtrier a pris
soin qui n plus aucune trace qui permett
de l'identifier trop de
coïncidence naime pas beaucoup la
coïcidence de la
police si c'est le même individu qui a
commis les deux crimes alors ça ne peut
pas être palomino barios il était en
détention provisoire au moment du
meurtre de marie-hellène le Péruvien est
donc remis en liberté Marie-Hélène est
la troisième jeune fille à disparaître
dans le quartier de la gare la seconde à
être assassinée dans les mêmes
conditions à Perpignan l'angoisse
s'installe il y a la psychose qui se cré
les gens à la gare n'osent plus sortir
alors que c'est l'endroit où le plus
vivant peut-être de Perpignan jusqu'à
présent là c'est terminé c'est fini et
surtout si on est une jeune fille brune
avec des cheveux longs un peu sportive
et
jolie la police judiciaire est sur les
dents tous les immeubles proches de la
gare sont fouillés tous les habitants
tous les commerçants sont interrogés le
parvis de la gare est surveillé 24h sur
24 on a également fait une chasse à
l'homme une chasse au détraqu et sexuel
de la région mais comme rarement ça a
été fait tous les commissariats et les
gendarmerie de la région nous nous nous
indiquit toute information dès qu'un
fait à caractère sexuel était commis à
rien rien jusqu'au 9 février 2001 ce
jour-là Fatima hiidraou ne rentre pas du
travail elle se volatilise à perpignon
dans le quartier de la
gare de suite on est allé au
commissariat j'avais pris une photo avec
moi et là dès qu'ils ont vu la photo là
par contre le le com m'a pas caché que
qu'il avait peut-être une inquiétude par
rapport justement à la ressemblance avec
les autres filles qui avaient
disparu là ça a été le coup de
massue parce que notre première pensée
c'est de dire ça y est le tueur de la
gare a de nouveau
frappé depuis 1995 Fatima est la 4e
jeune fille brune qui disparaît au même
endroit à la nuit tombée cette fois la
chance va sourire au enquêteur grâce à
un témoignage capital les policiers
identifient rapidement une voiture puis
un
suspect il s'appelle Marc delpèche il a
34 ans marié père de famille il est le
patron du San Diego un bar de jeunes à
perpignon
entendu par les policiers l'homme passe
rapidement aux
aveux Marc delpèche raconte qu'il a
connu Fatima à la caisse du magasin où
elle travaillait elle serait devenue sa
maîtresse le soir du 9 février 2001 il
aurait pris Fatima en voiture et une
dispute aurait éclaté entre
eux il me dit j'ai perdu complètement
les pédales je sais plus ce qui s'est
passé elle criait je l'ai étranglé je
l'ai étranglé et très rapidement j'ai
pris conscience qu'elle était morte et
là il me fallait organiser quelque chose
Marc delpèche explique s'être débarrassé
du corps de Fatima au large du Cap Béar
à une quarantaine de kilomètres de de
Perpignan il l'a transporté tout seul à
la nage en pleine nuit une version que
les policiers ont bien du mal à croire
la suite va leur donner raison le 13
mars 2001 le cadavre de Fatima hiidraou
est découvert à moitié enterré au bord
de l'étant de Canet en Roussillon à 500
m seulement du domicile de Marc
delpèche tout le monde s'est posé la
question est-ce que nous avions arrêté
le tueur dans sie de la gare de
Perpignan
difficile certains magistrats certains
policiers pensaient que non d'autres que
oui parce qu' il y a des différences il
y a des différences notables
fondamentales entre le le le le
traitement surtout des cadavres
mocttaria elle est exposé avec des
découpes corporelles précises et
nettes Marie-Hélène est dissimulé s des
détritu avec des découpes
grossières Fatima est enterré sans
ablation sans
découpe des modes opératoires différents
voilà qui laisse les enquêteurs
perplexes tout comme les déclarations
ambigues de Marc delpèche il a toujours
laissé
planer un doute sur sur d'autres faits
qu'il aurait pu commettre il y a eu des
courriers très énigmatiques où il disait
qu'il allait être amené à avouer
d'autres d'autres choses pour rester en
prison et pour ne plus faire de mal son
codétenu qui qui nous avait révélé que
Marc delpèche lui aurait dit un soir
qu'il se
sentait pour chasser ou persécutter par
trois
femmes de sérieux doutes mais aucune
preuve formelle les enquêteurs
perquisitionnent le domicile de Marc
delpèche et font une surprenante
découverte dans son ordinateur une
ébuche de roman il écrit un petit texte
de quelques lignes une quinzaine de
lignes qui s'appelle Tati
et qui raconte la rencontre entre une
jeune femme qui fait du stop sur la
route de tuire à la descente d'un train
et qui va rencontrer un éventreur je
crois criminel le héros parlait à la
première personne en substance il
racontait que il descendait la vun laare
en
voiture prenait à droite la rue
Courteline il apercevait sur le trottoir
une jeune fille en train de marcher
un coup d'œil devant un coup d'œil dans
le rétro personne pas de
témoin je m'arrête la jeune fille se
penche à ma portière je lui demande si
elle veut que je l'amène quelque part
elle accepte avec un grand
sourire je démarre et je
continue le chapitre s'arrête quand
l'homme prend la route de tuire avec
Tatiana à ses côtés je dois
reconnaître que c'est troublant et je
pense que s'il y a eu un meurtrier dans
laaffaire Tatiana il a agit de cette
façon j'entends parler de Marc delpèche
lors de son arrestation pour le meurtre
de
Fatima à l'époque c'était vraiment on
recherchait un cérial killer quelqu'un
qui aurait fait disparaître toutes les
jeunes filles donc peut-être je me dis
peut-être que c'est lui aussi pour
Tatiana puis euh
au bout de quelques jours on retrouve
dans les affaires de Tatiana une affiche
euh du saint-digo donc qui est le café
que Marc delpèche avait en gérance et là
c'est un sentiment de panique terrible
parce que je me dis si Tatiana avait
cette affiche dans ses affaires c'est
qu'elle allait au San Diego et c'est
qu'elle a certainement croisé Marc
delpèche un sentiment terrible
de déjà de peur de peur et puis de dire
comment va va-t-on faire pour montrer
que qu'il a rencontré Tatiana qu' a
croisé Tatiana que c'est peut-être lui
qui l'a fait disparaître pourquoi ce
sentiment de
peur peur parce que quelque part on a
quand même ce petit tout petit espoir
euh de dire peut-être qu'elle é dans une
secte peut-être que effectivement elle
est partie au bout du monde et qu'un
jour voilà on a toujours quand même
cette pe ce petit espoir même s'il est
minime et là lorsqu'on arrête mar che et
qu'on fait le lien avec laffiche qu'on a
retrouvé Tatiana qu'on découvre chez
Delpêche une esquise de roman qui parle
de Tatiana là on se dit que c'est lui et
là on se dit c'est fini on ne verra plus
Tatiana malgré de fortes présomptions
impossible de confondre Marc delpèche
pour la disparition de Tatiana et pour
les meurtres de mocttaria et
Marie-Hélène un des juges d'instruction
qui avait repris le dossier à la fin le
juge Boyer lui a été a passé des des
mois et des jours et des nuits à la
recherche d'un sanctuaire ce qu'il
appelait le sanctuaire de de delpèche
persuadé que delpèche avait un endroit
où il avait gardé conservé toutees tous
ces objets et qu'il allait s'y
recueillir des recherches qui restent
vaines Marc delpèche est finalement
renvoyé devant les assises uniquement
pour le meurtre de Fatima
le procès permet d'établir avec
certitude que Fatima et Marc delpèche
n'ont jamais été amant la jeune femme a
en réalité été étranglé après avoir été
violé en juin 2004 Marc delpèche est
condamné à 30 ans de prison assorti
d'une peine de seté de 20 ans un verdict
confirmé en appel un an plus
tard le mystère des disparitions de la
gare reste entier l'ombre du tueur en
série H toujours perpignant les meurtres
de mocttaria et Marie-Hélène sont
toujours impunis et le corps de Tatiana
reste
[Musique]
introuvable aujourd'hui à Perpignan
personne n'oublie le dossier des
disparus de la gare les journalistes
continuent à faire vivre l'affaire et
les enquêteurs ne lâchent rien
[Musique]
José belmondte cette affaire elle a
feuilletonné pendant 20 ans et il y a
plusieurs générations de policiers qui
ont travaillé dessus c'était important
de de de pas lâcher l'affaire
effectivement tous les inquiéteurs qui
sont restés donc avec moi nous avons
toujours travaillé travaillé travaillé
sur ce dossier et nous avons jamais
voulu lâcher cette affaire là n nous
sommes dit qu'un jour ou l'autre on aura
un nom ou des
noms
c'est les les nouveaux inquiéteurs qui
sont arrivés quand nous nous sommes
partis nousons dit voilà on vous
transmet le dossier surtout ne laissez
jamais tomber faites en priorité
travaillez en priorité dus travaillez
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
[Musique]
jours travailler pour qui est la vérité
c'est aussi la mission d'Étienne Nicolo
depuis 20 ans il est l'avocat des quatre
familles des disparus de Perpignan
Étienne Nicolo comment êtes-vous arrivé
dans cette affaire alors de façon
indépendante chaque famille de victime
au fur et à mesure des crimes qui
étaient commis ou des disparitions qui
survenaient m'ont contacté une seu de
ces quatre affaires a été résolu quelle
est votre priorité le temps passant il
faut faire un S sorte d'abord qu'il y
ait pas prescription des faits donc il
faut que j'alerte régulièrement les jeux
instruction pour leur demander
d'entendre les famille qu'il y ait donc
des actes qui permettent une
interruption de la prescription il faut
savoir qu'intelligemment et la police et
les magistrats ont fait en sorte qu'il y
a toujours quatre dossiers et pas un
dossier dans lequel on aurait cherché un
assassin unique l'avantage aussi c'est
que ces quatre dossiers étaient confiés
au même jug d'instruction même quand ils
se sont succédés et aux mêmes enquêteurs
en sorte que les enquêteurs les
magistrats et les partis civiles ce qui
était mon cas avait une vision globale
des disparitions même si on cherchait
dans chaque dossier en
particulier une veille juridique
attentive qui permet aux enquêteurs
d'exploiter tous les éléments nouveaux
c'est ainsi que le 9 mars 2006 plus de
20 ans après la disparition de Tatiana S
ouvre une piste
inédite on découvre dans un chemin peu
fréquenté au Boulou donc à à peu près
une quinzaine une vingtaine vingtaine de
kilomètres de Perpignan un
crâne ce crâne est celui d'une
adolescente il a été exposé à l'air
libre environ une dizaine d'années et la
calotte de la boîte crâenne est découpée
évidemment les policiers se disent que
ça pourrait être le crâne de Tatiana
Marie José Garcia comment apprenez-vous
la découverte de de ce crâne j'apprends
la découverte du crâne au
Boulou par la radio et c'est terrible
c'est terrible parce que là j'entends un
crâne vieux d'une dizaine
d'années qui appartiendrait à une jeune
femme et là je me dis c'est Tatiana
c'est une partie de Tatiana donc c'est
terrible c'est terrible parce que là je
repense à moctaria je repense à
Marie-Hélène je repense à ses corps et
là je me dis c'est Tatiana qui a subi le
même sort et et voilà il a fallu
attendre beaucoup de mois très long
interminable pour arriver à savoir si ce
crânne appartenait à Tatiana l'ADN
n'étant pas exploitable vu euh le séjour
qu'il avait fait à l'extérieur c'était
encore plus difficile de savoir si
c'était elle ou pas après d'après la
denticien et
d'après différents fciè en fait la
police judiciaire m'a dit que ça ne
pouvait pas correspondre à Tatiana c'est
un soulagement c'est oui c'est un
soulagement terrible parce que moi je
j'ai très très peur que ma fille ait
souffert j'ai très peur qu'elle ait subi
le même sort que moctaria et que
Marie-Hélène c'est un soulagement et en
même temps on se dit on repart à
zéro
les policiers ont les indices prélevés
sur les corps et les scèes de crime pour
élucider les meurtres de moctaria et de
Marie-Hélène en 2012 les progrès des
expertises ADN et la réforme des textes
de loi permettent enfin l'exploitation
de ces
cell les enquêteurs décident de
s'orienter sur des cell qui n'ont pas
été analysés encore donc ils vont faire
un tri une sélection de 34
qui vont être envoyé au laboratoire
biomis à Lyon pour faire des
expertises sur lesquelles on compte
vraiment parce que c'est vraiment les
expertises de la dernière
chance en octobre 2013 les résultats
tombent l'acharnement des policier est
enfin récompensé on a deux profils ADN
masculin distincts qui proviennent l'un
des restes découvert sur la scène de
crime de Marie-Hélène gonzalz et l'autre
de de trace laissé sur la chaussure de
mcttaria à
shaib pour les familles l'espoir est
énorme elles ont désormais un élément
tangible cet ADN qu'on retrouve ça vous
donne de l'espoir
oui parce que on n'a jamais baissé les
bras et puis on avait confiance à la
justice
et
toutes ces années comment vous les avez
vécu vous avez été aidé non on a eu
beaucoup de souffrance toute la
famille j'ai TR
enfant et tout le monde a
souffert et on a vécu dans la
souffrance et de pouvoir un jour savoir
connaître moins la
vérité
les policiers comparent ces empreintes
génétiques au profil de la quinzaine de
suspects apparus au cours de l'enquête
parmi eux palomino barios le médecin
puvien dans son cas seul l'ADN peut
faire jaillir la vérité puisqu'il est
mort en juin
2012 cet homme retrouvé mort en Espagne
a été étranglé on ne sait toujours pas
leur qu'il est qui est son assassin et
ce qui s
passé autre suspect que l'ADN pourrait
bien confondre Marc delpèche condamné
pour le mortre de Fatima hiidraou il n'a
jamais été poursuivi pour les autres
crimes est-il passé entre les mailles du
filet des comparaisons génétiques sont
opérées tous les rapprochements sont
négatifs aucun ADN ne correspond avec
les suspects palomino barios et Marc
delpèche sont mis hors de cause donc
évidemment à ce moment-là on passe à
l'étape suivante qui est de comparer ce
profil génétique avec le le fichier
national des empreintes ADN l'ADN
retrouvé sur les cellés de Marie-Hélène
est inexploitable il est trop dégradé
reste celui retrouvé sur la chaussure de
mcttaria et là c'est le coup de théâtre
d'un coup ça matche et les enquêteurs
réalisent que ce profil génétique
correspond à celui d'un homme qui a été
fiché pour agression sexuelle et qui
s'appelle Jacques
rançon
c'est quelqu'un qui est passé on peut
dire à travers les mailles du
filet même si on s'apercevra assez
rapidement que pas vraiment qu'il a
quand même un passé judiciaire assez
lourd et un parcours de prédateur c'est
en Picardie sa région natale que Jacques
ranon débute son parcours criminel en
1974 il a tout juste 14 ans lorsqu'il
agresse une adolescente de son village
Jacques Ron lui a sauté dessus il a
tenté de l'étrangler elle a crié une VO
est arrivé son père est arrivé et
Jacques ranon a pris la fuite le père de
la jeune fille l'a rattrapé il l'a
emmené jusqu'à la gendarmerie après lui
avoir collé une bonne raclée et
finalement la famille n'a pas porté
plainte donc l'affaire en est resté
là la première plainte contre Jacques
rançon remonte à juin 1992
elle est déposée par une jeune femme qui
de de 20 ans qui rentrait de discothèque
et elle est sur la route et Jacques
rançon lui fait une queue de poisson et
il l'emmène dans un chemin isolé là il
la menace avec un couteau il la viole il
la dépouille de tous ses biens de son
argent et il la laisse partir et cette
jeune femme va déposer donc la première
plainte Jacques ranon suite à ça sera
incarcéré immédiatement et il sera
ensuite en juin 94 condamné par la Cour
d'Assise Damien à 8 ans de réclusion
criminelle
une fois libéré en
1977 Jacques ranon veut prendre un
nouveau départ loin de sa région natale
il décide de venir dans le sud
expliquet-il au hasard il prend le train
il arrive dans la ville plus au Sud de
France qui est
Perpignan il loge dans un hôtel près de
la gare de Perpignan qui est une zone un
peu interlope puisque on est quand même
la dernière grosse gare avant la
frontière espagnole et sur la route de
Barcelone donc on a beaucoup marginaux
il vit d'expédient il vit de petit
boulot il est chariste magasinier il
travaille à Saint-Charles il va beaucoup
sur Facebook pour occuper son temps
libre il entre en contact avec des
jeunes filles via des chats et
cetera en 2005 il rencontre Lolita une
jeune fille de 16 ans et demi il en a 44
le couple s'installe à deux enfants une
vie rangée mais lil ne dure
pas
il semble qu'il soit violent qu'il la
frappe et donc au bout de 7 ans de
relation cette jeune femme décide de le
quitter et il le vit très très mal et il
se met à la harceler jusqu'au moment où
il va manquer de la tuer il va tenter de
la tuer elle va sauter par-dessus le
parapet d'une route pour s'enfuir et
elle lui échappe de justesse Lolita
décide de porter plainte et Jacques rçon
est condamné à un an de prison c'est à
cette occasion que les policiers
prélèvent son ADN et que son profil
génétique est versé au FNAEG le fichier
national automatisé des empreintes
génétiques une opération décisive
puisqu'elle le confondra quelques mois
plus tard pour le meurtre de Moktaria
shahib avec son parcours en plus de
l'ADN Jacques ranon est le suspect idéal
le 14 octobre 2014 il est placé en garde
à
[Musique]
vue Xavier Capelet vous êtes l'avocat de
de Jacques rançon qu'est-ce qu'il vous
dit quand vous le voyez en garde à vue
lui il m'ique ce stade là il il n AA
tout de cette affaire qu'il n'est pas au
courant donc ça ne lui évoque rien non
on le remet dans sa cellule de on le
remet dans sa cellule donc au repos et
je m'en vais et on vous appelle dans la
nuit on me rappelle quelques heures plus
tard effectivement m'indiquant que mon
client souhaite faire des déclarations
et comment ça se passe
là il est assez Vasif d'abord euh il
essaie de rassembler ses souvenirs euh
ce sont des faciens qu'il a essayé
d'oublier il donne les grandes lignes il
explique bah qu' se baladait ce jour-là
dans Perpignan c'est un soir le temps
est pas vraiment Clément il fait
quelques gouttes il rentre à son hôtel
mon shbelle rentre chez elle hein cité
universitaire
elle est sur l'autre trottoir il
traverse le trottoir et puis là les les
choses s'enchaînent il la menace il la
menace d'une arme d'un couteau en
l'occurrence
il a contraint à à le suivre dans un
endroit un peu plus isolé puisque sont
dans la rue et puis puis voilà et puis
l'oblige ensite à avir un certain nombre
de gestes don sur lesquels je je
m'étonnerais pas aujourd'hui il le donne
le motif
aussi pas vraiment il explique c'est un
peu l'effet du hasard il rencontre cette
jeune fille soir alors qu'il se balade
en ville et puis et puis voilà et puis
elle a elle a la malchance que ça tombe
sur elle
finalement là à ce momentl parle de
pulsion il explique pas vraiment son
geste il a il a du mal à à expliquer ce
qui se passe à ce momentlà qu'il a ce
genre de comportement on sent qu'il se
passe quelque chose de fort oui tout à
fait c'est très fort parce que c'est 17
ans d'enquête qui qui qui trouve d'une
certaine façon une conclu en ce momentl
des aveux glaçants 17 ans après les
faits le meurtre de Moktaria shahib est
enfin
élucidé mais pour la disparition de
Tatiana onujar et le meurtre de
Marie-Hélène gonzalz Jacques ranon est
formel il n'a rien fait le 16 octobre
2014 il est mis en examen pour
assassinat et placé en détention
provisoire à la Une aujourd'hui les
aveux du suspect dans l'affaire des
disparus de Perpignan pour le moment il
n'a reconnu qu'un viol et un assassinat
celui de Moktaria shahib on en sait
beaucoup plus sur la personnalité de cet
homme sur ses précédentes
condamnations Mohamed shaiib comment
avez-vous appris ce qui est arrivé à
votre sœur h par la télévision par la
télévision et après j'ai appelé de suite
mon avocat qui m'a bien
confirmé qu'il avaient qu'il avaient un
suspect qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
quand vous voyez ce visage cet
homme
déjà bien-être ça fait du bien ça ça
enlève quelque
chose une boule dans l'estomac ça lève
çaenlève çaenlève quelque chose dans le
cœur aussi un gros poids
et ça fait du bien aux yeux parce qu' il
y a un visage qui se met en fa c'est
chose que vous attendez pas de toute
façon et puis en fait vous vivez avec ce
mal que vous rendez plus compte quoi et
le jour où c'est vrai que vous savez que
c'est
lui une nouvelle vie qui commence en
gros c'est un nouveau démarrage parce
que c'est c'est quelque chose de de
lourd que boulz que vous portez en vous
quoi que vous vous rendiez même plus
compte quoi même sur une cellule
psychologique tout ça personne ne peut
vous l'enlever je pense qu'il y a que
que cette étape là qui peut vous
permettre de de de rebondir et de d'être
soulagé
quoi vos parents pendant toutes ces
années comment ils vont et vous comment
vous avez vécu l'attente de pas
savoir
il a démoli mon père mon père ça l'a
démoli ça parce que je peux
comprendre ça peut que vous démolir de
toute façon moi je me mettrai à sa place
et j'ai me F lu arrive ça je pense que
ma vie elle est foutue quoi tu as plus
le coup de de la vie après c'est pas
possible c'est pas
possible et vous
moi moi je me suis détruit pendant pas
mal d'années je me suis
détruit c'est pas la
[Musique]
solution
l'arrestation de Jacques ranon est très
largement commentée sa photo s'étale
dans tous les journaux et ce visage
réveille de douloureux souvenirs chez
une femme une jeune femme enfin une
femme à ce moment-là qui a 36 ans le
reconnaî notamment à travers le sourire
un peu carnassier de Jacques ranon qui a
une dentition en particulièrement
mauvais état ça l'avait frappé à
l'époque reconnaî l'homme qui l'a
agressé dans un hall d'immeuble avenue
de la gare donc à côté la gare à
Perpignan c'était en mars
1998 cette jeune femme rendait visite à
sa mère arrivé devant l'interphone elle
est tombée né àné avec un homme
complètement ivre Jacques rançon et lui
a parlé il lui a dit que c'était son
anniversaire et cetera et d'un seul coup
il a sorti un couteau et il l'a
poignardé et il s'est acharné sur elle
il a continué à la poignarder alors
qu'elle était au sol bien évidemment
elle a hurlé les voisins sont arrivés il
a pris la
fuite la jeune femme restera 3 semaines
à l'hôpital l'affaire sera rapidement
classée et son agresseur jamais
inquiété malheureusement cette affaire
là nous n'avions pas été mis au courant
et ça c'est c'est c'est vraiment dommage
si vous aviez été mis au courant vous
auriez fonctionné autrement ah si si on
avait été mis au courant pour cette
affaire justement de cette femme
agressée de suite on aurait repris jacqu
et à ce moment-là je pense que on ne
l'aurait pas lâché du tout cet
individu les enquêteurs n'ont pas fait
le lien avec le meurtre de Moktaria à
cette époque ils pensaient tenir le
tueur le fameux médecin péruvien
palomino barios voilà pourquoi Jacques
rançon a pu continuer à vivre
normalement c'est assez incroyable de
penser qu'il a pu aessant rentrer chez
lui à quelque part le lendemain le
quartier était verrouillé par les
policier et lui était là à quelques
fenêtres de là il voyait les policiers
de sa
fenêtre la liste des victimes de Jacques
ranon ne s'arrête pas là une autre jeune
femme se manifeste auprès des policiers
elle lui a miraculeusement échapper
c'était en septembre
1997 2 mois avant le meurtre de mcttaria
Jacques ranon venait de poser ses
valises à perpignon alerté les
enquêteurs reprennent les dossiers et
procèdent à des v
lesau se
resser là en prison il est extrêmement
isolé il est coupé de sa famille son
fils ne vient plus le voir ses ex-fmes
ne viennent plus le voir donc il est
seul apparemment il entend des
voix du fond de sa cellule il est en
prison à bzier et donc à ce moment-là
les enquêteurs se disent que c'est
peut-être le moment de de le faire
craquer donc ils le mettent de nouveau
en garde à
vue devant les policiers Jacques Ron
reconna cette N nouvelle agression mais
il ne s'arrête pas là il avoue
spontanément le meurtre de Marie-Hélène
gonzalz il reconnaît rapidement très
rapidement tout de suite même mot
d'opératoire c'est la même chose encore
c'est un peu différent puisque là il a
prend un stop c'est très très près de
chez lui là encore une fois qu'il a qu'
a prend en charge dans sa voiture au
départ pour la ramener et assez
rapidement je pense que d l'instant où
il l' effectivement prise en charge euh
je pense que l'idée de l'agresser lui
vient assez vite et à quel moment il la
tue dans les dans les minutes qui on
suivi puisqu'il l'amène à un endroit un
peu isoléin à l'extérieur de Perpignan
et et puis là il
l'agresse il la tue et ensuite on c'est
qu'il a effectivement décapité et qui lu
a coupé les mains d'après ses
explications pour effacer ses traces
il les viscè
pourquoi pour accélérer je suppose la
décomposition du
corps
ça me fait un soulagement qu'enfin on
peut connaître la vérité au bout de 18
ans qu'est-ce que vous attendez
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
j'attends j'attends qu'il
crève j'attends qu'il aille pourir en
prison et que il recommencera plus à
faire du mal aucune fille
il a détruit la vie de ma
fille aussi la
nôre il a détruit notre viille et celle
de ses
frères et pour nous on va vivre le
restant de notre
vie avec l'image et le nom de celui qui
a enlevé assassiné notre
fille
qu'elle n'a rien demandé juste rentrer
chez d'elle rentrer chez ses
[Musique]
parents rançon a-t-il fait d'autres
victimes la liste pourrait-elle encore
s'allonger d'autant que son parcours
contient des zones d'ombre où était-il
entre
1998 et 2005 pourquoi arrête-t-il de
tuer après le morurtre de
Marie-Hélène je pense qu'il est possible
que Jacques Renson est dans d'autres
département commis d'autres crimes je
pense d'ailleurs que
aujourd'hui nombre d'enquêteurs dans
d'autres département vérifie si Ranson
n'est pas passé dans le coin si il n'y a
pas une convergence ou une similitude
avec les crimes de perpinien qu'est-ce
qui vous fait penser ça ah je sais que
les enquêteurs dans d'autres
départements font des vérifications
c'est pas parce qu'ils font des
vérifications qu'il y a forcément
quelque chose non mais on peut imaginer
aussi que ranon ne sa'est pas du jour au
lendemain arrêter de commettre des
crimes alors qu'il était sur une
trajectoire dans laquelle il n'hésitait
pas agresser systématiquement des femmes
et à les tuer si elle résistait on peut
partir aussi du principe qu' n'
strictement m'a rien fait et d'ailleurs
j'attends comme disent ou comme montre
des victimes parce que pour qu'il puisse
être accuser quelque chose encore fa
qu'il a des victimes à lui vous lui avez
forcément posé la question bien entendu
la réponse ben la réponse je la garde
pour moi puisque c'est entre lui et moi
il nous cache encore des
choses je peux pas vous répondre si lui
vous
disait j'ai tué telle personne à telle
époque qu'est-ce que vous devez faire en
tant
qu'avocat rien
vous êtes obligé de le dire de le
révéler je pense
pas s'il le faisait vous le vous le
diriez je sais pas ce que je ferais s'il
me le disait très sincèrement je ne sais
pas il vous l'a dit je vous répondrai
pas à cette
[Musique]
question le procès de Jacques rançon
pourra permettre de lever ses doutes il
devrait intervenir à la fin de l'année
2016 si les meurtres de mooktaria et de
Marie-Hélène semblent résolu la
disparition de Tatiana andujard reste un
mystère il est aujourd'hui avéré que
jacqu ranon était en prison à hien
lorsque la jeune fille de 17 ans a
disparu en septembre
1995 le dernier mystère de l'affaire des
disparus de Perpignan à un nom c'est
dujar où est-ce qu'on en est de ce
dossier alors j'ai autant d'espoir
aujourd'hui que l'on découvre euh le
celui qui a fait disparaître Tatiana
dujard et qui l'a probablement tué j'ai
autant d'espoir que l'espo que j'avais
que l'on découvre les assassines de
Marie-Hélène et de moctaria pourquoi
parce que on a aujourd'hui déblayer le
terrain les enquêteurs n'ont plus à
chercher
le responsable de trois crimes ils n'ont
plus à chercher que le responsable d'une
disparition mais c'est le dossier dans
lequel ils ont moins d'éléments on n'a
pas de corps on n pas de corps mais il y
a toujours eu des pistes qui ont été
explorées qui ont été abandonné parce
que peut-être aussi et c'est ce qui me
donne l'espoir on les rattaché aux
autres meurtres aujourd'hui on va les
reprendre toutes ces pistes enfin les
enquiéteurs vont les reprendre en
cherchant chaque fois à aller plus lo et
je pense que on peut imaginer que un
jour on découvrira ce qui s'est passé
avec Tatiana j'espère vraiment qu'un
jour on aura une réponse qu'on sera
qu'on sera
soulagé quelle que soit la vérité aussi
terrible
soit-elle c'est de toute façon mieux que
d'attendre comme on attend sans avoir de
réponse parce que dans notre cas dans
mon cas je passe des nuits à
imaginer ce qu' a pu subir ma fille et
on imagine tout tout ce qu'il y a de
pire on l'imagine on imagine qu'elle
était enlevée on imagine qu'elle est
dans la mafia on imagine qu'elle est
prostituée quelque part qu'on la
contraintte à se prostituer on imagine
qu'elle est dans une secte on imagine
qu'elle est séquestrée quelque part on
imagine qu'elle est morte on imagine
tout et ça c'est terrible donc quelle
que soit la vérité aussi difficile
soit-elle je préfère savoir la
vérité aujourd'hui comment t
allez-vous je
fais je m'efforce d'aller
bien pour mes
enfants parce qu'ils sont ma raison de
vivre mais c'est très compliqué il y a
des jours où je vais je vais bien je
travaille j'ai une vie sociale j'ai des
amis mais c'est très compliqué si je
dois faire un bilan je dirais que je
vais très
mal